hello everyone we're here at cube Con in
Barcelona with me is Aparna Sena she is
director of product management of
kubernetes and that's right can you
start off telling us what anthos is sure
anthos is our hybrid cloud offering
that's based on kubernetes sto and our
multi cluster management control plan
that's hosted in the cloud
we're here at cube con this conference
is all about open source
how does GK you relate to open source
and why is there such a big presence of
Google here why the Google presence
Google is the originator of the
kubernetes project it came from our
history with borg as you know you know
we've been running containers in
production for 15 years now and we're
launching billions of containers new
containers every week even today so
that's why Google is here we're very
very passionate about this project we've
have hundreds of engineers and product
managers that are working on the project
and have been since the last five years
as you know it's the fifth anniversary
of kubernetes and so we're having a
birthday celebration here it's also the
fifth anniversary pretty soon this year
of gke so gke was started pretty much in
parallel with kubernetes it is our
hosted version of kubernetes running in
Google Cloud Google kubernetes engine
and it is you know the oldest most
mature most stable and widely used
distribution and and hosted offering of
kubernetes in use today so we're very
very excited about both kubernetes as
well as gke and they actually have
really built off of each other so
another component of anthos that I'm
really interested in is its do can you
tell me more about that yeah as you move
to micro services you you find that you
actually have a lot of services in your
environment and you need a good way to
manage those services
and and in particular you want to be
able to you know monitor the services
have observability about which services
are talking to which other services to
be able to set policies on those
services from a security perspective and
to be able to control traffic when you
need to and this is the essential
function of us F and s re inside Google
you know a site reliability engineer you
know developers are not typically the
ones that are making sure that the
service is you know up and running or
studying the security policies and with
SEO and with anthos in general what we
do is we allow the ability for that
separation of concerns where you can
have an SRE or operator type role that
is doing the service management that is
taking care of monitoring securing and
ensuring the reliability of your
services through that traffic management
so that's the capability that we provide
with SEO and then the combination of
that and it CN anthos configuration
management which lets you from a single
source of truth set policies both
configuration policies security policies
are back quota these types of policies
across your Multi cluster environment
allows you to do that from a single pane
of glass that's really what enterprises
need particularly as they have these
multiple environments whether they're
you know different retail locations or
on-prem and different data centers and
cloud the configuration management
capability and the service management
capability is how they're able to
standardize and manage and have that
that operations team that can take care
of the environment freeing up the
developers to do their coding and take
care of the the business functions that
their business requires so it sounds
like the anthos ecosystem is going to
provide a lot of very awesome
functionality to customers very soon so
last question is what are you looking
forward to a coupon this this week well
I'm looking forward to your keynote
that's definitely a big highlight I'm
looking forward to meeting a lot of the
ecosystem in the community here you know
another part of anthos is our
marketplace so we've got a marketplace
in Google Cloud and what we've done
in our workloads team is you know we've
got the application object and we are
working with a lot of the community here
a lot of the ecosystem to create
containerized forms of their
applications whether it's in the form of
operators or just you know containers or
some other package that they that they
that they want to use and then
publishing it to the marketplace in the
ng CP and that marketplace is then
available to all anthos customers
whether it's on gk or it's on gk on-prem
and they can deploy those applications
out you know just out of the out of the
gate with support from the from the
ecosystem so we're really bringing the
open source ecosystem to Google cloud
users and I think that has a
multiplicative effect and is a is a big
reason to be here it's a big reason to
you know to really build on
Madonn what we've done with the
community that sounds awesome thank you
so much for your time Aparna
[Music]